is a tool that analyzes metagenomics  data this culture-independent microbial  communities what we basically learn  about them is composition and function  of  these communities  and it can be applied in a bunch of  areas like agriculture healthcare where  we can study microbiomes of different  organs  or ecology where biosensors are  developed using  metagenomics and biodegradation of  plastic is also a bacteria during  process and of course biotechnology so  on the platform we  present three modules pre-processing  that  consists of filtering and denoising  algorithms then we go on to taxonomy  with silver classification filtering our  classified sequences and conducting  philogenetic trees  then we can move on to metrics to  calculate for alpha and beat the  diversity